you
hello and welcome to the fundamental
investing with use of programming
tutorial part 2 in this tutorial we're
going to be covering some of the basics
of where we're getting the data and then
maybe we'll start to build the program
to actually hold this data so we're
going to be going to get our data is
going to be Yahoo they seem fairly
friendly towards people using programs
to read their website they've never
given me any trouble so that's what
we're going to use and so if you go to
the finance section of a yahoo you know
you can put anything in here that you
want so like let's say we actually want
to look up Yahoo so we can put in Yahoo
and they've got like all kinds of data
on the company first of all you could
always just you could parse Yahoo prices
they've also got bid ass that's updated
you know fairly frequently and also the
volume here bid asses some good data
there but what we're looking for is
fundamental analysis kind of stuff and
so to get there what we want to do is
scroll down on the side here and there's
all kinds of stuff there's the income
statement which we'll be using a little
bit there's also balance sheet and cash
flow all of this stuff is actually
really really beneficial there's not
only the annually earning or annual
earnings reports right but also you've
got the quarterly earnings report so if
you view the annual ones it'll go back
for you basically two years like watch
the three years really
so this December you know 31st 2012 31st
2011 31st 2010 so you can immediately
get historical data back three years for
the annual earnings and then quarterly
data goes back I want to say just a year
yeah but uh probably in some future
videos I'll be showing you guys how to
acquire even more data than that but
we're also not going to be using that
just yet then we've got the income
statement that you can go through again
you've got annual and quarterly you've
got the balance sheet again
annual and quarterly and then cash flow
and again annual and quarterly also you
have key statistics which we're going to
look at in this video and probably the
next few videos and here you can find
all kinds of well key statistics on the
company they've got market cap you've
got enterprise value PE trailing in
forward PE G price sales price to book
enterprise value all that you've got a
profit margin operating market you get
the idea it's just a bunch of statistics
that really are genuine generated by
using all that other data that I was
just showing you like the income the
balance cash flow all of that so you
could either you know go through and
track those numbers yourself and then
generate these numbers or you can look
at this and this is kind of generated
well I think it's generated pretty much
every day so and it will compare it you
know to current price right the current
stock price so for example like
price-to-book is what we're going to
look at first so the price to book ratio
is basically what is the you know the
public's valuation of this company cuz
their stock and then so all you have to
do to find the value you know is take
the stock price how many stocks are
there multiply those together boom
you've got tech companies value and then
the book value is basically like the
value of the company's tangible assets
minus all of their liabilities basically
so any debt that they own and so on
that's going to be subtracted from that
and that's going to be like the book
value of the company so if this company
was to go out of business let's say and
just basically sell everything that they
own how much money would they have after
paying back because the first person to
be paid is the debtors you know and then
finally maybe the stockholders get some
of their money back but usually
stockholders are just kind of screwed so
in the case of Yahoo for example their
price is twice what their Book value is
which is actually kind of a low price to
book ratio for a tech company but still
nonetheless they're worth double
what their actual tangible assets minus
liabilities are and so for when it comes
to value investing that's the first
thing we're going to look for one of the
statistics that you're going to be
looking for is a price-to-book ratio
that's and you know about two thirds of
like the price is currently two thirds
of their a third is tangible value right
so they're clearly devalued so if they
were to sell everything they'd still
have thirty three percent of their value
that they could give to shareholders
obviously you would still take a loss
right you would need price-to-book ratio
to be like zero okay for you to get your
money back for sure but it just kind of
signals that this company is somewhat
undervalued now it's not a sure fire
method of course because you know it
could almost be a signal that something
is very very wrong with this company if
their price to book ratio is under one
and you can't quite figure out why you
you might want to just leave that
company behind also it could mean that
there's just a fundamental flaw in the
business and also there are some
businesses where you might not even
understand like all of their assets you
know so you might not even understand
like what's being included in their
assets like banks and investment kind of
stuff it gets really really messy really
really quick to understand how that adds
up whereas if you let's say you're
looking at like Chipotle which I believe
has like a nine or something let's look
at what it's what it is you can add up
to pote lays where is it press to book
yeah nine point two at the moment
but you can at least understand like
Chipotle okay well if you were to sell
all the restaurants all the stuff inside
the restaurant so you know what they
have whereas when it comes to some
companies you don't quite understand it
and that's kind of one of the
fundamentals of fundamental investing
especially value investing it's that you
understand the company and you
understand how they make money because
if you can't understand that kind of
stuff then you need to walk away so some
people do understand banking but most
people don't and so some of it so
sometimes it's best to just kind of walk
away if you don't understand how their
book value is
generated so what we're going to be
doing I think I'll cut off the video
here in the next video what we're going
to do is discuss how to build this
program that will visit the any stocks
key statistics page and pull the price
to book ratio for you and basically what
we'll end up doing is making it at like
a screening program like we'll say if
the price to book ratio is under this
number tell me so that's what that's
what you have to look forward to if that
sounds interesting to you then continue
on to the next video as always thank you
for watching thank you for your support
your subscriptions and until next time